the Arab Spring blossomed across North
Africa in the Middle East Barack Obama
has been reelected before Edward Snowden
award is for those Forgotten children
for education charlie hebdo's marriage
equality the British people have voted
to leave the European Union worst
refugee crisis fight for your lives
before it's someone else's job no well
tik-tok ADHD inept for Old Town Road
became the longest-running number-one
single in billboards history the
ventures endgame officially the
highest-grossing movie of all time the
Emmy goes to
Phoebe Waller praise the United States
of America champion
okay boom ice Trump it's now ordering
federal government workers to go back to
work without getting paid it's official
the government shutdown is now the
longest in US history there's no sense
that there's any room for the two sides
to really find a compromise both are
digging in we have Big Macs with water
pounders with juice we have everything
that I like that you liked reason we did
this is because of the shutdown we need
border security we have to have a
despicable living conditions migrants
live in standing room cells for a week
the United States is running
concentration camps on our southern
border special counsel robert muller has
delivered his final report if we had had
confidence that the president clearly
did not commit a crime we would have
said so President Trump is maintaining
that there was no wrongdoing on his part
in his phone call with the president of
Ukraine a history-making headline the
third time in history a sitting US
president impeach the 2020 presidential
race is heating our pill yes we're gonna
take your ar-15 your ak-47
[Applause]
who can beat Donald Trump
Oh me remember no one is above the law
and that includes the President of the
United States
coilette anunció guitar a renunciant Oh
a mere cargo the proceedings I have not
been able to deliver Rexha Stefano
India is counting votes for the world's
biggest democratic election Narendra
Modi has swept to a crushing general
election win tensions rising between
India and Pakistan over Kashmir the
long-planned
Turkish military operation in Northeast
Syria has been launched chaos in
Venezuela both the opposition leader and
president Maduro are calling for
supporters to protest
[Music]
we are witnessing a wave of
demonstrations around the world from the
Middle East to Latin American the
Caribbean from Europe to Africa Asia
[Music]
there is a growing deficit of trust
between people and political
establishments and rising threats to the
social culture
one could say what's in store what's
lurking around the corner she's been to
the chief super nice just to change that
syriza remains on its future they have
every right to fight it a teenager from
Sweden called the voice of the planet is
ready to cross the Atlantic on a mission
to fight climate change the ice of all
future generations are upon you and if
you choose to fail us I say we will
never forgive you
[Music]
this is the start of a day of global
climate strikes inspired by teen
activist Greta tunberg you are failing
us but the young people are starting to
understand your betrayal
[Music]
a new United Nations report warns the
impacts of climate change are increasing
an inevitable and environmental disaster
with global implications the Amazon
rainforest is burning at record rates
New Delhi air pollution is putting the
health of millions of people at risk
their cyclone that is swept across
southern Africa Kerala for a second
consecutive year is battling floods in
some districts hurricane durian
devastated the Bahamas please pray for
us please pray for us everyone please
pray for us we have seen what we thought
was unseeable Taiwan will be the first
Asian country to legalize same-sex
marriage we are not immune to the
viruses of hate of fear of other we
never heaven but we can be the nation
that discovers the cure the answer lies
in our humanity
the first man to run a marathon in under
two hours we are here and we have to do
something nurturing that we respect
before we go to love somebody to take
care of somebody exactly to make one
other person feel good and that just
seems to make life not just livable but
a gallant gallant event
[Applause]